[Music]
this morning on the dish one of la's new
hot spots mother tongue launched by chef
michael mina the cuisine is a reflection
of the private fitness club it sits
above to lead the kitchen and help
create the menu mina tapped fernando
darine as executive chef whose interest
in yoga and clean eating made him the
perfect choice for what mother tongue
has named a new culinary dialect
it doesn't feel like a
traditional restaurant nourishing the
mind and the body that's the intent of
mother tongue the patio here is probably
my favorite executive chef fernando
darine says it's a concept built into
the restaurant which occupies the top
floor of the social and fitness club
highmat a name that means the feeling of
home the name of the restaurant mother
tongue was a very easy reflection of
what highmat is we wanted to take
all these dishes
from around the world
and transforming it into our own mother
tongue
simply put it's comfort food from around
the world but all made using nutritional
ingredients without sacrificing taste
a challenge chef fernando as he's known
at mother tongue embraced i took this
project because of the challenge and
because this reflects
my lifestyle as well i like to eat clean
i like to cook clean and the food that
it's on that menu is a reflection of
that take mother tongue's version of a
traditional bread service pita alongside
three colorful and flavorful dips you
can mix the colors and you can make a
painting if you like there's a syrian
based walnut mahamura
i love this one a beet hummus and an
avocado and tarragon mousse with the
antioxidant spirulina on top they all
have like very distinct flavors but like
they got your mouth
going along with health there's also a
focus on sustainability like in the
mother tongue lamb we use a not so
popular cut the neck which is very
flavorful and a very sustainable thing
cured for two days roasted for five to
six hours then shredded before being
served in a papaya it feels good to be
using the cuts not everyone thinks about
using it that lamb is like melt in your
mouth each offering also maintains a
focus on comfort and multi-ethnicity the
brazilian mojeca a seafood stew served
with rice toasted yuca flour herbs and
onions
fidowa a cousin of paella made with
lobster shrimp and roasted citrus all on
top of a thin noodle instead of rice the
noodles get crispy yeah so there's a lot
of texture going on the cultural fusion
reflective of chef fernando who grew up
in brazil with an italian heritage the
italian food that i know
is not the italian food that is in italy
right it's an adaptation
uh with brazilian ingredients and this
is what i love not to get too attached
to the recipe the right ingredient
itself open your mind and that's when
true
creativity can flow since he was a kid
chef fernando has had his hands in the
kitchen learning the cooking basics from
his grandmother she would make me help
out and she would make me stir the
polenta which i hated it because it was
just like four hours stirring that
polenta it started all very very young
but you didn't
think this is going to be my future in
cooking when you were no no
when did that change for you
i think it it changed when i moved to
los angeles i came here just to stay for
a few months honestly and i knew this
guy
that introduced me to this great chef
called eric greenspan two years later i
was his sous chef
one door started to open and another
door another door and then i was like
15 years later i'm still here while he
may call it an unintended career it's
combined perfectly with the one he
thought he'd have as a musician playing
guitar there are so many chefs that we
talk to
that music is their other passion is
there something there is there it's very
connected i feel that's a very
similar thing about
conducting an orchestra
and conducting a kitchen
are you ready steam the way that people
work together
it's very similar i'm even thinking in a
recipe it's like i need a little more
violin or i need a little more spice i
use that a lot yeah that analogy i say
this needs a little eq
like a little bit more base or a little
bit more uh lids
fats and oils yeah are like the base
and highs vinegars and lemon
the right combination
harmony something mother tongue strives
for in each item on the menu oh my gosh
it's ever popular rizzoni a perfect
example orzo corn puree and strachatella
cheese with black truffle shaved on top
it's a very simple dish but i honestly
think that simplicity is the ultimate
sophistication another mother tongue
mantra played out in dessert
this yeah
[Music]
this is wonderful
which for us was an indian inspired
carrot cake pudding with cardamom cream
and pistachios i'm going to go back to
the menu because we started talking
about the challenge of creating it but
how much fun did you have in creating
the menu it's probably the most fun part
of opening a restaurant i like to go and
i like to watch the table it can be a
sounds a little creepy
sounds a little creepy but i don't do
that often but i like to see you know
people's reactions and probably the most
interesting
reaction that i ever got in my cooking
career really because i feel like here i
was able to translate my personality to
its fullest
to the menu and people acknowledge when
something is true you know something's
not fake the menu here is
truthful to what i am
as is the beverage menu we talk about
that health and all of that the balance
it's there too even with like spiked
kombuchas this is their bourbon bee one
thing i want to point out chef fernando
practices yoga and that balance he and i
talked about that you find in yoga is
something he brings to the kitchen as
well you feel all of it in that
restaurant love it chance hit hollywood
he knows a guy i want that dessert